what did you just say matt oh we got an
intro first
what's interesting i was gonna play a
creed song for the chord or podcast
but then i didn't because it's creed
it is a licensed music well you're going
to and then matt dropped us a truth i
grew up
i dropped a little bomb on you guys drop
the bomb
um matt drop it again because we were
early i'm dropping it again for the
audience
um my mom was in a cree a creed music
video
uh called my sacrifice
oh yeah you do the sacrifice
i guess so i don't know what that music
video is about because it has mermaids
and a younger version of scottsdap and
then an
old man version of scottsdale oh i don't
even know
and yeah she was my mom was holding an
umbrella in the rain if you guys want to
go back to that music video and relive
your childhoods
um my mom was holding the umbrella she
had a blue dress on
and i auditioned for the kid that's
under the car
and i almost got it with that son of a
[ __ ] some cuter kid
got it and i could have been it could
have been me man and your real mom is
now holding
your fake son yeah
she's looking over my real son should be
here but yeah
he's not cute enough wasn't pretty
enough not for scott
did that immediately catapult your
family to international fame and fortune
believe it or not no not at all
but it was it's cool it's cool though it
was shot on the universal uh
studios a lot um in florida yeah in flor
in orlando florida
and they flooded the whole park for some
of these shots
so freaking creed yeah i was just also
saying like so basically we got onto
this subject because
uh jake was ripping off he's gonna touch
my focus if you're wondering what i'm
doing
and adjusting a couple of the chords you
hit like instantly like reminded me of
creed i was like are you playing creed
welcome back to the chorus
it's episode 97 today yeah you know
creed is one of those bands that for the
last like 15 years
i never revealed that i used to really
like
yeah but like i don't i think i was in
like fifth grade fourth or fifth grade
when i was like creed's cool i jammed to
some creed it wasn't that bad
it just yeah yeah music was good no one
knew they were a christian rock band
and then like it came out they're a
christian rock band and everybody's like
oh that's not cool they were the trojans
christian kills the whole rock and roll
vibe you know
you know if you want to sing gospel
songs you know go ahead but
but the whole like posing as a rock band
while you're doing it
kind of goes against the whole sex drugs
rock and roll thing wasn't there
but okay scott stapp was his name
yeah wasn't he didn't wasn't there like
a leaked like sex tape of his or
something like that i don't know we're
like
there's a bunch of women around him and
he just looks straight at the camera and
is like
it's good to be king wow
that's the thing yeah i don't know i've
never seen it i just read about it one
time in an article at some point in the
last decade
i believe that that fact stuck in my
head i was like what
he was a rock star man i mean i believe
that just
right in that wave of christianity yeah
in the creed nickelback era
you know they should really just team up
with nickelback and go on tour i think
yeah they should
yeah double feature yeah
that would be the ultimate didn't
nickelback do like the main song for
spider-man it wasn't nickelback it was
it was like the lead singers
yeah was that the second spider-man
movie and it was
it was the lead singer of nickelback
with another band
or spider-man this is
[Laughter]
song right no the only hero can say
there's a really good foo fighters song
called my hero that's
you know yeah of the same era yeah and i
was hoping it wasn't that because that
would have really killed
the foo fighters vibe for me
yeah thank god they got past that one
do we need an intro here should i play
an intro or did we just do it i mean we
can
just just play the song real quick okay
[Music]
there you go oh thanks sweet
so uh so today was kind of a big day in
the studio not kind of today was
actually a real big day
yes it was every day's a big day in the
studio but uh today we had scott adkins
come in and join us for stuntman react
and founder of the adkins diet right
yeah um wait no surely not right okay
okay you had me going there you had me
in the first half
freddy uh freddy put it well when he
said scott adkins is probably one of the
three
best active like martial artists on film
in the world um did he say that on the
couch cause freddie was a co-host
yeah he was a co-host today um
he did not he sit on the couch before
scott was here before we were filming
um but it's like it's like you have tony
jaw
and the guy from the raid and scott
atkins
wow wow you know i mean there's more
obviously you know it's like obviously
jackie chan is like still doing some
acting and stuff in terms of like you
know
guys that are out there actually doing
the fight scenes and whatnot yeah
scott is really up there what are some
examples of like his most well-known
work
um so he has this uh the series called
undisputed um which is
a pretty well known like i think it's
like a kickboxing like a russian
underground kickboxing
like prison fighting movie okay um but
he's like he's in a bunch of stuff
uh he's like a bad guy in a lot of
movies um he's in the expendables too
he's a ip man four
he was uh he fought tony jaw um in a
couple of things
oh he was in it man four yeah he's the
main bad guy in hitman 4.
oh my god he is i didn't even realize
that wow
he's like super accomplished and he
shoots like four movies a year it's like
he's just out there doing stuff
and like dang it was really really
really encouraging to hear him talk
about he's like i just
was really into martial arts films when
i was a kid so i wanted to do it and
that's why i did and it's like
yes yeah yes you just said does he does
he say it with a cool accent though oh
yeah cause he's like
uh british or whatever yeah yeah um he's
got like this like british or whatever
well you know it's like it's like oh no
he's welsh actually it's like i don't
know the difference oh well
i mean that's fair no i don't i don't
know if he's well i'm just saying like
um but he also has like this like solid
like
baritone raspy voice which is obviously
a great asset to have if you're an actor
as well
so he's like this all the time
yeah and another cool thing about him is
that he he has
a youtube channel where he's doing a
very similar thing to what we're doing
but just like deeper dives into action
and once again it's like
imagine if matt damon
had a youtube channel where he talked
about like the ins and outs of acting
and had like guests on every week
and he just did it because he was into
it like that's what this guy is doing
but he's in the martial arts you know
cinematography world it's like there's
such a level of authenticity that like
is so encouraging to see others out
there that like have found success but
they're still like
really nice good wholesome people who
are doing it because they actively are
like in love with what they do it's like
oh it's yes it's so good the world still
has good people in it
all right i gotta know did you roast
eric we uh we didn't really scare lyndon
because we didn't have a fight scene
that we could pull up that was like a
specific example
um i did pull up two of our uh fight
scenes that we did hoping to have them
roasted
and scott just told us that we did a
good job
he's like these are legitimately good
you guys did a great job filming it i
really like them
and it was like oh i
[Laughter]
where it like zooms in on you and you're
like yeah sometimes i just i feel like
i'm not supposed to be on the couch
you know i gotta do a real stunt yeah
i'm surrounded by ghee and aaron tony
like literally both the black panthers
are on the couch beside me and be like
hi i'm niko
yeah not just both of the black panthers
all the black panthers
yeah yeah and and uh
falcon sorry uh black panthers stunt
guys yeah r.i.p
chadwick boseman yes but uh also it's
funny
not to hit too tired of a tangent here
we're gonna take a quick turn because
you mentioned uh
uh the box fall video hey i became a
meme for a little bit
i love that name so much it is so good
the moment i saw the first one i was
like yes yeah i'm so glad it's picking
up some traction and making the rounds
around
around reddit i'm just going to pull it
up real quick because
i think i only saw one it's been it's
been named
it's been memed a lot on reddit yeah uh
jordan
yeah that is i don't know if you can see
this clearly but
hey everybody today's a big day for me
because i'm going to be jumping off the
roof of this building
yep so of course you lead in with some
text as all memes do and it's like me
colin accidentally calls my teacher mom
it's a big day for me i'm gonna jump off
the roof of this building
i don't know who made that meme but it's
amazing yeah it was somebody on the
corridor subreddit put it together yeah
yeah yeah it started it and then it kind
of took off from there
but just makes me really happy because
like a lot of other people have had
memes like randy you've been in a bunch
of memes sam even got memed my favorite
meme
from corridor honestly it's an old one
and it's sam like sitting in this like
weird run-down lot where you're filming
sync or something like that
and it's just a bit of wisdom he says
you buy a man a console he'll game for a
generation
teach a man to build a pc he'll game for
a lifetime
that one makes the rounds on like r
slash gaming every now and then or a pc
master race
yeah uh ren you got i told you this
story but i'll tell the audience uh
ren got used in a natty one my wife was
in a group text with a bunch of people
and
somebody used a a meme of ren saying
something
like like really or yeah i think
i'm kind of impressed or something i
forget what i said
something like that and uh yeah they
didn't know
that you know wendy knows you obviously
they just used it
yeah but yeah so so scott atkins came in
and like
every once in a while we get like we're
somebody joins us in the studio or we're
around somebody who like
exudes like this extra aura of like
being extra human it's like human plus
like when we did the uh the tom cruise
deep fake like the guy that came in i
can't remember his name evan that's
right yeah evan
like we all felt like we met tom cruise
because evan had that
vibe that energy that aura yeah and like
scott atkins like possessed
not not the tom cruise or but just like
that heightened like man you're like
a human being that's like i meant scott
adkins i felt like i had met tom
but yeah like he had a level like of
wisdom and charisma and authenticity but
also like just somebody who's been like
so true to their vision that like
it just yeah you feel like you're you
can feel like this extra little bit of
energy coming off them which is cool not
to get all like woo-woo
but yeah it was really neat and
probably the the coolest thing was that
he comes in the place he's like looking
like oh hey cool just happy to be here
he like looks at me he's like you really
know what you're talking about in the
stuntman react episodes i'm like
but i did notice like both me and
freddie did a lot less joking this time
around because like we both were trying
to like you know kind of act like we
knew what we were talking about and
impressed scott a little bit like there
weren't like the goofs and gaffs quite
as much as just us trying to act like
you know insightful and put out good
questions i saw a comment at some point
i forget
where it was but someone pointed out
that when we have guests on for vfx
artists react
i at least tend to be less joking as
well it's like
not not less joking but a lot less like
me yeah just like like wild card me
right when we have a guest on and it's
like it's very true though it's like all
right
i'm sitting next to like someone who's
pretty legit i don't want to just like
embarrass myself by being
me yeah yeah i'm sure it's different
than just like friends on the couch
talking about vfx
if freddie's there was freddy that's no
big deal and of course like when it was
you me and clint we would goof around
all the time that was like
a lot of what made this show special and
having a guest on is special too
just a different kind of special yeah i
notice both we all offer up a lot less
information when we have guests on like
legit guests
like we'll we'll ask questions but we're
we're way less inclined to like throw
out
like here's how they did this shot
you're like it's like i'm not here to
tell you this stuff for this episode the
guest is here to tell you that
i mean that's the point you know like
you don't you don't want to step
into where the guest space is there to
offer yeah you know
the the video gold that effectively they
have to offer to people
it would be kind of weird if you invited
somebody like that on and then we're
like okay scott let me tell you how this
was done
yeah yeah exactly yeah and it's not even
like that stuff doesn't happen i feel
like on the cutting room floor
it's like we want to focus on the guests
you know more more than anything like
yeah sure you guys throw things out
there um
and that's great but usually what ends
up in the cut is the stuff that you know
the guests are saying
and you guys are bouncing off of yeah
imagine if all the episodes of hot ones
were just
i forget the guys the main hosts yeah
sean
that's right sean he's just asking them
to ask him questions
yeah yeah exactly yeah but like i mean
nico
brought up that point and i think it's
pretty good it's like it's not just a
matter of
uh trying to do things for camera as
much as just like
here's someone who actually knows some
of this uh
some of the back end type stuff for what
we're looking at
i have real questions and i have real
desires to learn
what this person knows yeah so
i think a lot of that ends up coming
across on camera as opposed to us
goofing around because it's like
who like sam or nico on the couch like
i might have a real question but chances
are i already know what they're going to
say
yeah you're just as versed in the stuff
as we are at that point
because our skill sets are the same we
all do the same thing
bringing someone who works in the
industry their skill sets going to be a
little different
yeah even if we're all doing effects the
other reality of it too is like
even though we've like we've already we
have arguably quote-unquote and working
in the industry for
you know our 10 years now like youtube
just isn't the same industry you know
like youtube is not viewed the same as
like doing movies
um and so it's just it's not quite the
same legitimacy as like somebody who's
shot
films or somebody who's done tv shows or
that kind of stuff even if we've all
shot the same amount of hours of content
it just has a different vibe to it yeah
yeah yeah and and
you know back in the early days of vfx
starstruck like the first year so not
exactly early days but
i would definitely see some salt online
from like vfx artists who are like
i don't know what the right word for it
is not bitter
but kinda like that we're like getting
the success of views and whatnot
when they think we just don't know what
we're talking about because we've never
been in the trenches
oh you know working 80 hour weeks in a
yeah in a
working on some movie coming out because
the deadline is like in a month and but
we can totally relate to the working
hard part we've definitely pulled those
long hours but not in that pipeline not
in that workflow
oh hey guys brandi o'daniel here back
with today's sponsor story blocks now
i've brought out these blocks
these play blocks from my childhood
because i thought there'd be no better
way to teach you guys about the wonders
of storyblocks
than to use these blocks right here
so first example okay you got stonehenge
right that's where we're gonna get to
but before you get to stonehenge all you
have are stones
these stones are roadblocks to you and
your final product but because
storyblocks is the one-stop shop for all
your stock asset needs
you take these stones and you turn them
into
stonehenge that's right do you see this
now all of a sudden you can pass
through using storyblocks as high
quality 4k
b-roll audio motion graphics images
and more and you can pass from the
roadblock right to the story block they
also
are constantly updating their library
they have a virtually
unlimited library so anytime you come to
a roadblock
you can go back onto storyblocks and
everything that they have on there is
going to be new
and different for you this time around
with a storyblocks unlimited all-access
plan
you can use unlimited amounts of
anything that they have on storyblocks
for your videos
royalty free it doesn't matter if it's a
commercial
right it doesn't matter if it's a
youtube video or an instagram video or
even a movie it doesn't matter you can
go ahead and use
anything on there download as much as
you want whenever you want so anyway if
you guys are interested
all you have to do is click the link in
the description below
or head on over to storyblocks.com
corridor cast
and you can get started that's
storyblocks.comcast
and now back to the podcast
i think that's common though like on you
on youtube
specifically um people's people have
show formats that blow up and then
there's a lot of
i think especially when they initially
blow up there's a lot of hate
around that format because you perceive
the person as a they
they just kind of got this success or
they didn't they didn't put in the work
you know because it's it's such a
non-traditional pipeline
to you know notoriety or what have you
that i think that happens a lot i mean i
can tell you even personally like
when i mean this was this was about
this was a little while after mr beast
had already blown up but
i remember me being salty about that oh
i remember because
yeah because i was just like what is you
know what has he done you know but then
i went
i went and you guys were like no really
dig into his content and i really went
and i dug into his con and i was like no
this guy
knows his format and he knows what he's
doing even though it doesn't seem like
it it seems like he's just this
dude you know and who's doing all this
crazy stuff but he's he's
you know he's if you if you add up all
those hours and you add up all that time
it's like there's a wealth of knowledge
there that that he had to
do and go through to get to where he is
mr beast uh i think jimmy is his name
right
uh no anyway mr beast he's one of those
guys who seems like an idiot but is
actually kind of a genius
yeah like he has this era uh this uh of
like
or yeah that was like i said air i was
like that's not right either god dang it
of like kind of just like aloofness
nonchalant like oh yeah
10k yeah sure yeah and then like i was
like
sure yeah 100k yeah whatever but it's
like that it's
intentional you know it's like there's
there's a lot of uh
you know strategy behind how he acts and
also i a few people have experimented as
much as he had with
has experimented with formats right
yeah he spent a lot of time just
throwing a lot of stuff at the wall
until eventually a couple things started
clicking and you started just building
on that and
like vfx started to react i mean yeah
yeah the funny thing is the vfx rs react
you know back to like the being in the
trenches thing
like sam and i did we did
make a two or three trenches a little
bit you know it's like we haven't
obviously done it as much as like people
have been in the industry for a long
time
and maybe that's where like a little bit
of the like
divide comes in two or it's like imagine
you know you're in world war one you're
like
wow look at these trenches it's pretty
nuts cool i'm gonna leave see you guys
but i think that same attitude applies
to uh
how they view freelancers as well i
think it's about the camaraderie of
being at an actual like house like you
know
maybe not necessarily ilm but like you
know method uh
npc i can't think of any uh other houses
right now
yeah like all these you know visual
effects companies that hire you know
a couple hundred people and so you got
like these rows and rows of desks of
people just working long hours doing
effects
i've never once had a desire to join one
of those companies
it was never something i wanted to do
but i wanted to be a vfx artist
uh after i got of course within two
months of graduating college with a
completely different degree
but did you get your degree i did yeah
no i i have the diploma or rather i have
the degree and have never once to use
the diploma
do you know where it is i do yeah it's
in a box in my house
but yeah i guess what i'm getting at is
you know i i feel like they feel that
they have battle scars that they've
earned
and maybe they identify that we are
guessing about something
that they know is wrong and they can
just
you know put that up to our inexperience
in that setting but that doesn't mean
we're inexperienced
with visual effects right the flip side
of this though
is that i feel like people start kind of
expecting us to kind of be
not just vfx artists but like incredible
vfx artists
yeah which is kind of problematic yeah
as demonstrated by
uh the terminator 2 video that came out
recently
and also compared to delivering shots
that
what they're comparing to are whole
houses full of
people vfx artist instead of like three
guys
you know yeah yeah it can well the other
side of that is like
now because vfx artists has been react
has been so uh
successful like that is kind of our
brand
to a lot of the public is like oh we're
vfx artists like in reality
i consider myself a filmmaker you know
first and foremost um
you know i'm as much a vfx artist as i
am a cinematographer like right
it's these are all just tools and things
i need to do to be able to make stuff
and
i think that's what made the vfx rs
react series for myself at least why it
worked for me is that
i could approach it not just as a vfx
artist but as a filmmaker as an artist
as an audience member as a fan as
you know as a million different things
and give it all those perspectives so
it's not just being viewed from within
the one box but from the entire picture
um which is what you do too as well you
know ren and uh
you know we all we all we all bring
different like angles towards it that
aren't just vfx react angles
i mean it's as simple as like bring in
the whole like physics side of you know
vfx um like you don't necessarily have a
lot of physicists that are also visual
effects
artists you know so you have a lot of
musicians that are also visual effects
artists you don't have a lot of actors
that are also visual effects artists
i will say i know a physicist a
theoretical physicist who is also
a pretty good visual effects artist
really his name is henry and he runs the
youtube channel minutes
that's right you know henry henry reich
he's also a very good fiddle player yeah
that's right yeah i'll never forget the
time you guys were playing at vidcon
and you started playing i think it was
like you started mishmashing the game of
thrones
song with the skyrim song yeah i just
remember thinking this is the coolest
song i've ever heard live oh my god
so along the line of fiddle players um
i think that there's an analogy here
the traditional vfx houses are like an
orchestra
you know it's like a bunch of people and
you have first chairs and you got second
chairs and you got
people that are just there to try to get
one of the chairs
and then we're like a we're like a banjo
band
you know we're like we're like a rag tag
we got a fiddle we got a banjo we got a
guitar
slide maybe there's a guy that plays
this whistle
yeah well that that music
can be interesting but it's never going
to be the same
thing as orchestra an orchestra will
never be the same thing as
fiddle music
to add on that i think we're more of
like a banjo band and all of us know how
to play a bunch of different kinds of
guitars
you know it's like we can play a bunch
of different guitars but it doesn't
necessarily mean we're that good at any
of those guitars specifically
we're not all joe satriani or yeah yeah
but we know how to do three chords in
the truth you know and
get and get the message out there the
song and people see it and they're like
oh that was really good and then
the orchestra is like oh gosh it's so
ghastly how could they
you know yeah that's it you know to be
fair they're also a lot of other vfx
artists of these places that do enjoy
the channel
oh okay you are totally right i'm not
we're not trying to
rag on all the hard-working full-time
vfx artists out there in my creating
symphonies yeah damn them in their
symphonies
from the people i've actually talked to
uh in the professional industry who have
worked like you know i've talked with
artists at ilm
at mpc uh their general perception is
appreciation for what we do because
we are you know making visual effects
not
just more understandable to the general
public but also more fun
and there's a lot of value in that i
think we're i think we've probably
inspired a lot of people to get into
this industry that wouldn't have
otherwise
and and that's really cool i'd that
yeah it's awesome i think that's super
cool too like i'm
i hope we can encourage people to you
know get turned on to
arts and passions that they're like into
and follow those things and
you know every person that comes along
that we can help even just a little bit
in that regard is like
i mean that makes it all worthwhile you
know um
i think i've told this story before but
i'm going to tell it again uh
so be right before i was going to
college um i was talking to my grandma
and she's a you know a really nice
person
uh super sweet or she was a really nice
person super sweet she passed away last
year um
uh and i wasn't expecting to do this but
she challenged me she goes like all
right nico you're a smart guy
why aren't you going into medicine you'd
be helping a bunch of people you know
why are you going into film and like
she'd been super supportive up to this
point i was like i was totally not
expecting her to be like
what the heck why are you doing this oh
no and
it was like it had to pause for a moment
because she had basically challenged me
like you know any
anybody out there who's like you know
hard-working and smart and you know
going out to do things like what are you
doing for the betterment of everybody
else
you know why why aren't you doing this
for somebody else
why aren't you doing things for other
people and there's a pause there it's
like well
i think with filmmaking i can entertain
people and you know inspire people and
you know tell stories and help people
find you know
those truths about the human condition
you know obviously i'm like half bsing
my way through this question
but while slightly sweating yeah and
she's like good answer
um but there's a moment where you know
it's a little bit less about my answer
to her and more about pausing and
thinking about like
that is something i need to think about
regardless of what i'm doing whether i'm
doing
filmmaking or whether i'm going to go
off and try to become a research
scientist and come up with a cure for a
disease like
what is it that i'm doing with my time
and efforts that's going to help other
people
and like now pausing here and like
looking back what i've done with youtube
like we've gotten enough
messages and emails from people that
said like hey you helped me get into my
my job or you could help me find my
passion where it's like yes i did it
grandma
i pulled it off i actually called her
maymay i did it
so yeah uh and then and then uh and then
a
the sound of john f kennedy's inaugural
speech comes on
and he asks what you can do for your
country and not what your country
can do for you and this decade
[Laughter]
yeah every time anyone mentions that i
have to say in this decade
um yeah no it's it's been an amazing run
so far
and uh i can't wait to see what the next
year of it brings and who we can get on
and
you know how we can take it even further
i mean it's
yeah it's pretty incredible yeah no it's
been it's been really cool i mean
it's crazy because like you know today
was a big day scott atkins came in but
it's like
i guess i was on vacation last week but
the week before was a big week i jumped
off the roof of the building you know
it's like
every week comes with like a crazy thing
here and like you teach your mom
after calling my teacher mom i jumped
out there
but yeah it's it's like everything's
been like this whole
being able to do something new every
week can be a blessing and a curse
and it all kind of depends on how you
look at stuff but i've i've found it at
least right now to be very much a
blessing to be able to like explore
something fresh
uh frequently uh a week at a time
because
so many other people are grinding on
something for so long and they're tired
of it and they're done with it
and you know so it's like sometimes yeah
it'd be nice to look at a
a project for months and work on it and
just like you know
make that one thing as cool as you can
make it like yeah it'd be fun but like
you know do not take it for granted that
we get to have the variety that you know
that our life has right now because
variety is the spice of life as they say
yeah as they say helps my adhd a lot
yeah yeah one of the things that i
appreciate most about this job is what
you're talking about nico the the
ability to
like do all these different things all
the time but also
i'm i'm able to like you know lead a lot
of these ideas
and i really love that i love being able
to like
come up with an idea and see it through
to completion however
something that i've come to realize is
that when you do too much of that it
starts getting
it's it's a little taxing perhaps
which is why i wanted to do these james
bond effects
i wanted to put myself in a situation
where i didn't have to make any creative
calls
yeah yeah i don't want to figure out
what to do
tell me what to do and i will do it at
least for a little bit and then i'll go
back to like you know
yeah i'm making these other things you
need a break from that stuff yeah it's
very
mentally i spent the entire last week
and and whatnot just like researching
all the solar stuff and
it's just like at the end of it like it
was literally like full-time study work
and i'm because it's like it's not just
a matter of
studying information it's trying to
figure out how that's going to factor in
with this other information
for the point i want to make is this the
right point i want to make is this the
right point in time that i want to make
that point
oh you mean i just have to cut james
bond in half i can do that
draw some music slice them up sure
that's the kind of fun creative work
that's not too mentally taxing but you
know has its own problem solving that's
just fun well this has been matt and i's
chance to
take the lead on it you know yeah yeah i
wish i could have done that a little
more last week but
it's all good yeah i know you were sick
but even though still what you put
what you put together in the initial
edit i was able to jump on and leapfrog
on
and you know and then now you're able to
come in this week and take another pass
on it
yeah forward to it yeah yeah i think
there's something pretty
pretty cool there oh i know what we
could talk about now oh
i was gonna say it i was gonna say it
too yeah so
that's crazy so there is this program
called
ai video upscale i think it's got some
kind of
general name like that but it's from a
company called topaz topaz labs topaz
labs and they make a bunch of ai image
processing apps
they're all like anywhere between 100
and 300 a pop
most of them are for like photography
stuff for like upscaling your image
denoising it bringing stuff from out of
focus into focus
uh colorizing it all driven by
uh machine learning models that are
trained on i don't even know what they
trained it on but
they've got this trained model and that
is their software now uh one of their
programs
is basically built entirely around
upscaling low resolution footage to high
resolution footage
and it works shockingly well yeah yeah
but matt and i were experimenting with
this today and it can break down
yeah with it's not great for everything
yeah
but what it's really good for and what i
applied it to today
is a very specific uh piece of bts
footage from
um honey i shrunk the kids uh honey i
shrunk the kids the bts
anywhere on the internet is super low
quality like we're talking like
200 pixels it was literally like i think
it was 200 by 140
140 or something crazy like that and
that footage
was a scan of probably vhs yeah
it was scanned but 100 scanned on a vhs
tape
um so that's all we were working with
and it was
what we would normally look at when we
look at footage like that uh as editors
we go
well we can't use that we have to figure
out a way to like supplement this
without using the bts footage
but we use topaz i i ran it through
topaz
and it totally worked it made it look
sharp enough to where we could actually
use the bts footage as supplements for
what we were talking about on honey i
shrunk the kids
and it was uh it was great it's a very
useful tool for stuff like that
what are the fallbacks of it so some of
the fallbacks are the fact that like
it is still i mean nico you could
probably touch on this better than i can
it's still like
it can't make anything it doesn't
already understand
and sometimes it will like let's say i
was working on this james bond shot
and one of the shots it like crisped up
his face like
really nicely you can kind of tell like
when you zoom in it's more of like kind
of a
smooth almost like an oil painting type
look to it but when you
zoom back out and look at it wide it's
just the detail is just like
very high-res and it looks great but for
this other shot the background was out
of focus
and it made the background in focus yeah
it literally
like removes the depth of field yeah but
only in sections
sections yeah like like so for the
silhouettes of human bodies it'll make
it super sharp but then right next to it
in the background is super blurry like
how the original footage was
so it's like this weird like in focus
out of focus right like it was able to
identify machinery that was out of focus
in the back
and make it really crisp and sharp and
stuff like that and there's this
you you're looking at one of the shots
from honey and shrunk the kids that
it actually even added text to a sign
yeah really but that was completely out
of focus yeah or
not out of focus as much as just like it
was so low quality and blurry that like
you couldn't there wasn't any detail
there yeah and suddenly it was a sharp
sign it almost looked like an
like a downward facing arrow with a
bunch of characters
in it and it generated those characters
because it's been trained on signs
and so i bet uh we were talking like if
you're to go
actually try to read that sign i bet it
just says gibberish yeah it was it was
just gibberish yeah and so it's
but it recognizes that like oh yeah
usually when we look at signs there's
these weird like blocky shapes that look
like this and
yeah it just probably made some random
blocky shapes that kind of at a glance
look like
text but isn't a lot of that sort of
stuff happens and then
more than anything you see especially
with the that footage blowing it up as
much
it gets really weird around the faces
and it almost looks like there's a
keyframe
like iframe type moments where it's like
every second like you can kind of see
the image just shift
in in places yeah because because doing
something that's temporarily consistent
is yeah yeah yeah so
when in in the world of vfx and
filmmaking you have
uh spatial uh resolution and things like
that so spatial is basically just
referring to
an x and y axis thing aka your image you
have
you have basically a graph that is
colored in with pixels and that's your
image
um but you know you're in the world of
movies you don't just work with one
image you work with images over time so
then you have temporal
you know resolution things like that
it's like you know the temporal
resolution of a movie is 24 frames per
second the temporal resolution of a shot
on the slow-mo guys is like a thousand
frames per second
and when you're doing something that has
like say ai up scaling or you're
processing an image
you can process a single image it can
make everything crisp but the next frame
that it processes
needs to be temporarily consistent with
the previous frame in other words your
details can't flicker or jump like that
sign for example you're talking about
where it just made a fake sign out of
the blurry sign
the the next frame when it does that
again the same symbols need to be in the
same spot
yeah and that's uh that's a really
challenging thing which
you know it's one thing to do with
images it's nothing to do with video and
you know topaz labs obviously pursuing
those problems with gusto it's like uh
as far as temporal consistency goes
think of this analogy it's like imagine
you have
100 frames that you have to rotoscope
this person out of or some random shape
and it's like kind of detailed
there if it's just one artist working on
it you know they'll do like the first
frame last frame
and then like work in the middle and
like kind of keep things consistent over
time
just as naturally as you would as a
single artist but if instead
you kicked out that 100 frame shot to
100 different people
each working on one frame from the whole
sequence
and then compile all of your stuff
together there's going to be some weird
things like maybe one frame this person
got
really hyper detailed about rotoscoping
the gaps between fingers
and then the very next frame the guy's
like mitten
yeah and we should try that and see how
it goes
i mean we know how it goes that's
exactly where i would go
flickering that would be more noticeable
than if you just had the mitten around
the whole hand the entire time
versus like you know one person maybe
did like the spock hand type deal then
the other person did all five fingers
and the next person did mitten
it's like ai is only looking stuff
one frame at a time so that's where that
inconsistency comes from
is because it may see and understand an
image later on but it doesn't understand
the context of where that image came
from earlier on in the shot
yeah now there are ways to you know go
about doing this there's like style
transfer to kind of carry things through
uh you can train neural networks
temporally there's uh
yeah one of the big things these days if
they have um you can do what's called
like
uh optical flow basically uh optical
flow is a really old thing it's been
around for a long time surprisingly old
yeah but basically it's optical flow is
uh computer just i mean optical flow is
basically how h264 works the the codec
that we see all the time it's just going
to look at your
blocks of color and patterns in the
image and as they move through the image
it's just tracking
this one thing and how it moves so you
can basically just have one element and
move that one element as opposed to
redrawing the element
you know fresh every single frame uh but
after you can basically feed an ai
optical flow then helps the ai know
what object is where and what objects
are moving from where and going where
and they'll help make things consistent
as opposed to think that every time your
hand is moving across the frame it's a
new
hand each time now as far as topaz goes
it's it's usually pretty dang good yeah
temporally but there were some some some
of the stuff that i was looking at that
you did for the honey i shrunk the kids
like
it got really weird with faces yeah and
it's a great example
of like how far you can push it and how
you how far you should push it
yeah because granted you were throwing
like a worst case scenario
if you guys want to look up like honey i
shrunk the kids behind the scenes and
look at
the youtube videos like it is just
absolutely unusable
it's horrible um so the fact that we're
able to pull anything from it is pretty
pretty pretty insane yeah and and the
program has a bunch of different models
uh that model that we are using was
specifically for like low resolution
uh yeah there's like models and then
options within those models you can
choose you can choose like
low resolution model and then you can
have it go for like compression like
artifacting blocky artifacting or just
blurry like it was just
low quality blurry footage which is
different from
compressed footage yeah or like maybe
there's some aliasing going on and you
got like jagged edges and stuff like
that and it's like
yeah it actually is pretty dang cool it
is it has it has different features you
can you can sort of refine for
yeah yeah okay you give it a set of
parameters that are based on like what
your
input footage is compared to what we've
had for the last
you know decade or so of basically
you can one you can just literally scale
up your footage
and the program will kind of just
blur the pixels together as it scales up
i i don't exactly know what
how that works but instead of seeing the
actual blocky
pixels just kind of get bigger they kind
of like do a like a four point average
yeah to buy a cubic something yeah by
cubic i think
so then after effects released this
and one of their new updates a while
back they released a
detail preserving upscale which is an
effect that i've used a lot where
basically you apply
that and scale that up within the effect
rather than the layer of the footage
and it does look a little bit crisper
like it actually
is a little bit sharper on some of the
details you could change a couple
different options one of them is by
cubic one of them is detail preserving
can reduce noise increase the sharpening
on
details and stuff like that but it was
only ever just as good as what you put
in you know you couldn't
stop inventing details exactly and
that's where the topaz thing is coming
in it's
literally inventing detail which is
when it works and some of these machine
learning tools are so
so awesome and to see them actually now
like
being utilized in our process is also
really cool because we've been
you know we've been sort of waiting for
this and hoping for it and watching it
evolve for the last few years but i feel
like it hasn't been
until really the last 18 months where
they've really started to
be part of our process yeah and even
then like
very few people are using it like we
were doing deep fakes before any studio
had
you know deep big people like only like
in the past couple months
i think ilm hired their first deep fake
artist like two months ago
we were using like little servers that
people put together and just kind of
were in some backwater of the internet
you know to do the processing yeah
yeah it's it's crazy like how little
resources are going in from a visual
effects company side into like
machine learning machine learning in
general like is being used all over the
place and i
i personally think machine learning is a
far bigger like
technological impact on society than
something like cryptocurrency is don't
get me wrong cryptocurrency is
interesting but like for the amount of
like news headlines that something like
bitcoin gets versus the amount of news
headlines machine learning gets like
machine learning is
way more of a game changer in my opinion
crypto is just making people a [ __ ] ton
of money so that's probably why
we're losing it or yeah i guess maybe
not right
actually we we we bought the dip today
so
about the dip
yeah actually i wanted to talk about
that a little bit because uh
um because it's it's all i mean most of
its base are from from news from china
again
um which has kind of been the catalyst
for some of the the drops that have
happened over the last three months but
basically they
they're continuing now with more force
to crack down
on the use of cryptocurrency it's it's
wild it's like i don't yeah i guess they
see it as a threat or something but
you know like obviously yeah it's nice
yeah yeah thing yeah i mean it makes
perfect sense when they're
you know autocratic as they are um but
yeah like uh that had that has this
effect and
you know and then today there was like a
huge huge drop but then
right but then it came back up about 25
from today yeah this morning this
morning at 7 00 am was a
pretty pretty sharp nip yeah oh yeah
yeah i wonder uh uh biggest dip in the
so far this year
yeah yeah well other than the fall
after the 6 6 000 level
yeah that that fall went down but yeah i
mean like as as in terms of like an
all-time low
obviously not in all time no but like
the lowest it's been this year well i
think there's a yeah
this year yep as somebody who is not
very informed on cryptocurrency i'm
gonna talk about it for a second here
niko's hot takes well they're kind of
not that hot they're microwaved slightly
hot pocket ticks pockets
i think i think we're reaching a point
now where there's actual
reckoning uh coming up against
cryptocurrency where
you know it's a concept everybody's like
this is a cool concept and now we're
hitting the points like cool can you do
anything with it
and obviously you can do things with
cryptocurrency but like now you need to
start that process it's kind of like uh
it's like it's like the dot-com bubble
that happened in 99.
you know it's like all these internet
companies are popping up and it's like
cool internet companies this is
definitely the future it's like yeah
you're right it is the future
so which one of you guys are actually
going to start making products and
making money
and everyone goes
you know it's like there's so many
different coins out there it's like
which coin is going to be yahoo and
which coin's going to be google
ecuador did just accept that i believe
they passed a bill
that i don't think it's gone into effect
yet i could be wrong but they just
passed something that said we're going
to accept it as
currency nationally which now has all
these other global implications because
now
say if the united states recognizes the
ecuadorian currency
well then now also it needs to recognize
bitcoin
um because that is now a national
currency a national currency of that
of that nation um so it it's
it's starting to bubble up and it has
been and that's kind of what caused the
initial run
at the beginning of this year and uh but
you're right i think a lot of it's kind
of now
fatigue in terms of like okay now there
was this huge run-up now
now what yeah now now like if it's going
to be a currency well there's a lot of
things that a currency needs to do that
none of the cryptocurrencies actually do
so it's like okay well gotta solve that
problem
but is that probably going to be solved
for bitcoin probably not bitcoin's a
pretty
old platform technologically speaking
it's probably going to be solved for
different types of cryptocurrencies and
so you got to kind of
what's going to happen where who's going
to actually turn it into a viable
product that you can actually utilize
who's going to come first network so we
can exchange it easily
you know you can't be you're it is like
early days of
dot-com because they all they all are
sort of tied to one another you know
when when bitcoin goes up they all do
and when bitcoin goes down they all do
and that's
that's a very clear sign of people just
looking at it as one industry
you know just going i i i it's good
bitcoin went down so that means
everything else should
yeah when eventually they'll de-link you
know
when those those actual products that
you're talking about start to
come to fruition i mean i've seen a lot
of correlation between
ethereum so far this year in bitcoin a
couple years ago a few years ago
like if you were to overlay the two
graphs they actually are very similar
and like
in their dips and rises uh the frequency
of them and the magnitude of them are
very very similar but you know we have
the next several years worth of bitcoin
of data
that we could just project for ethereum
but the problem
is that we've only we only have one of
those rounds with bitcoin even
and that was in 20 that was in 2017.
yeah you know when it got super hot in
and then it came down and so even the
history of it
you know we barely have any data sets
it's not like gold where it's like
we've had these data sets for you know
as long as there's been gold speaking of
freddy he had an awesome
hot take on uh here i
okay i have the tweet uh he says i have
logically deduced
the only way to become filthy rich off
crypto you must forget
you own crypto that's true
to continue it says uh to explain
there's an unknown percentage
chance that whatever you own will
eventually be worth an amount that makes
you filthy rich however
to get there the price must climb you
will be tempted every second
of every day to just take profit it's
like
who among you can say you will turn down
300 000 in your pocket right now
i'm reading this in freddy's voice uh
i'm accidentally doing an impression and
it's his hair's his hair is going like
this
he's saying it uh and yeah it's like
the only people who can resist that
temptation are fanatics thus non-fanatic
crypto enthusiasts i hereby offer a
service where you pay me to hypnotize
you
into forgetting you own crypto i will
send an email alert when your coin hits
up
hit your price target a key phrase
embedded in the email will cause your
memories to come flooding back
you will be shielded from the stress of
a price climb or the psychic turmoil of
losing all your money
if you become filthy rich congrats if
not here's you won't even know
here's the thing okay like nobody
becomes filthy rich off any one thing
like that's just not how it works you
know i mean except for the few lucky
lucky lucky ones but yeah you have your
outliers
yeah but but still like
logically speaking you know yes you
you could theoretically i mean my
brother was telling me the other day
there was
some guy that he works with that bought
dogecoin and he
he bought a bunch of it and then it went
up to 75 cents and he had like 750
000 in profit and he didn't want to sell
it and now it's
down to now it's down to 17 cents
um and he just lost hundreds of
thousands of dollars yeah
flat line people always forget the
second stage which is uh
sell high crash low high
ethereum and bitcoin back in early
january and so by the time like early
may was hitting i was like
oh my god this is amazing and then of
course i didn't sell
and now it's like i'm back to basically
how much i put in to begin with yeah
well you have to put that on a usb drive
forget about it for like a decade
and then come back to it i think that's
that's right first i have to dig it out
of the
landfill that it eventually ends up in
yeah
and then you have to find your
passphrase your seventeen word passes
yeah somewhere in the internet i do feel
like one of the things that perhaps
has made cryptocurrency
not clunky or cumbersome but like i
think one of the issues facing it is the
fact that it's referred to as a currency
and so just by the nature of that you
have a bunch of
financial bros coming in and trying to
make money off it play the stock game
off it do the day trading off
it it's like guys it's it's not even a
cryptocurrency yet like it's not a thing
yet like
you're always you're always suddenly
throwing millions and billions of
dollars around and like
[ __ ] with this whole system it's like
like hold up
hold up you guys all want to get rich
quick like get the [ __ ] out of here like
let me just work on that technology for
a bit that's not how the world works
though i know
but like better than that it's like you
don't quite have that same like
fanatical like pursuit of a technology
happening elsewhere like yeah you know
there's money to be made in all sorts of
you know sectors of technology but like
in the world of cryptocurrency like
that's what happened first anytime you
have
anytime you have that much volatility
with the amount of
visible potential that crypto has
i mean this happens in penny stocks this
happens in dot coms this happens in
marijuana stocks this happens and
it happens everywhere it happens across
whether it's stocks or crypto or what or
commodities whatever i mean not in
commodities but anywhere
um you're gonna get that and so
i think it's just a matter of like
balancing like hey uh
you know there's there's a long play but
then there's also short-term
short-term plays that you can make that
are based on that volatility
and and a lot of those people are you
know they're they're making money
on on both sides of it you know but it's
going up and when it's going down
yeah i just want to fly jet packs
fly jet pack i want to fly another jet
pack come on
you already flew one jet pack how many
more jet packs that you want
he's trying to commute with a jackpot to
work
like did you ever think he'd say i want
to fly a jet pack and you'd be [ __ ]
with you already did
you already did that i didn't
i didn't consider that that's kind of
yeah good point okay
yeah okay but back to that machine
learning thing for a second
um i think you're right i think there is
a huge impact i met this dude
at uh the airport on friday
when i was flying home and uh he was a
he's a i'm not going to get the exact
title right but basically he works for
facebook and his job is to come up with
and to improve machine learning
algorithms for
facial recognition in pictures and stuff
okay
um and so he was going on and on about
this and uh
he it was it was interesting because i
cuz he's like
what are you doing so i was talking to
him about deep fakes i was talking to
him about some how we use machine
learning
for bfx and so we had a nice little
conversation but
yeah i mean there's he was explaining
how there's entire teams
called red teams at you know facebook
google
what have you amazon and their job is to
basically
think like their competitors and so
he was on one of these teams and within
like the facial recognition
side of some you know deep root of
fat of machine learning that they're
doing with pictures and so his
job was to basically try to understand
like
how could somebody come in and either
make this technology better
or take it from us you know in ways that
we
may not have perceived and so his entire
job is to just
do that which is crazy because there's
these
you know there's these people at these
pretty high levels within
these tech companies that are doing that
and uh you know gets to the point where
it's hard for even someone like me
who deals with this stuff somewhat
regularly you know
and to to even follow
all the things that he's going on about
um
well yeah yeah man
algorithms it's dangerous you over
optimize and you lose the chaos that
makes life worth living
yeah yeah it's that's well put
you can you can create digital drugs
just by optimizing for every single
little dopamine hit that triggers your
brain
tic-tac-toe okay to play games
uh video games used to be good
one more thing um guys it's episode 97
today whoa but that but you know what
that means that means in three weeks
it's episode 100. wow what are we going
to do
what are we going to do now dang
yeah so we just hit the 100th episode
oh you know what's funny sorry to kind
of break this off we also
recently had 100th episode vfx artist
react
wow or our 100th react episode i should
say yeah not necessarily
vfx artist react but that was the
episode
that the red camera the wide camera was
out of focus for the entire show
run that through topaz labs actually
literally that would work it's just i
found
it kind of ironic cause i didn't didn't
even realize that was our 100th episode
until i saw uh nick's instagram story
about it like episode 100
still going strong and it's like yeah i
guess it has been two years of us doing
this
and uh that was the same episode that
i guess because the way we have it set
up we have a couch and we have two
cameras
right in front of the tv and the cameras
kind of block our view of the tv it's
kind of annoying to be completely honest
and
uh but it's just that's how it has to be
to make it work and the eye lines line
up to the tv then and then so the main
problem is that the red camera has this
huge
screen you know a big touch screen right
above the camera
and that's the big flag in front of the
just like just fold it down so
what nick does is he folds it down but
apparently
uh because we had been using the red on
another project with the
unreal stuff that sam was working on it
uh some settings didn't get auto focuses
on
auto focus was off on the lens but it
was you know how cameras are
someone touches the focus ring and all
of a sudden it's unusable
it was weird it was so weird so it's
like the whole intro the first like five
or ten minutes were in focus
and then you could see the camera just
like focus on the background and stay
there for the entire
rest of the two and a half hour shoot
was that this one was that the honey i
shrunk the kids one um it was one that
came out
recently um and we ended up i think
chase edited the episode maybe it was
dean but
ended up not using any of the red
footage
it was all just from the c100 yeah which
is the zoomed in
camera that whips around between us
there's no worse terror than filming
like a three or four hour episode
hitting the end
and then looking over like nick or dean
and they go i can't take a breath and
start poking us off you're like
what's wrong yeah i recorded it at
one-to-one compression
yeah yeah we've done that where it's
like
ran out of space we're like not quite
done yeah or like we we did finish or
something like that it was like
nick was like it ran out of space what
the heck recorded the whole thing at 120
frames
per second oh i remember that
it was like a couple hour episode in
slow-mo
it was five it was a 500 gigabyte file
it filled the 512 gigabyte card man you
could just speed the whole thing up and
like re-encode it
yeah yeah i think that's what they did
they processed it so that was actually
like usable but
yeah i mean i guess what i was getting
at with bringing that story up is that
it's
even after a hundred episodes dumb
mistakes still happen
yeah also even after 100 episodes
there's still so much to talk about
yeah so we were like how long are we
gonna be able to keep this up and it's
like
forever there's so much
there's stuff being created by people
yeah yeah and it's continuing to be
it's like created every day we still
have yet to do our spider-man 2 versus
spider-man 2 versus spider-man 2. that's
true episode
2 we haven't done uh we haven't
technically done the hobbit versus lord
of the rings yet no
there's there's been a few characters
that episode vfx artists react to
spider-man 2.
spiderman twos confused we've had a
couple ideas around this if there's one
before it
yeah uh there are a few ideas for the
couch
that we haven't done yet because we want
to be able to actually put a little bit
of research
into it the best episodes in my opinion
are when we actually come to the table
with some really cool insights
about how things were done and while
still trying to maintain that sort of
like reactionary like oh wow that's cool
which is very easy to do because it's
like you just look at something and it's
like what is your gut reaction
play on that and but being able to then
go
and describe the context for why this
looks the way it does or what was the
challenge behind it what makes this
special
if we're just looking at something we're
having a guess if we can actually go
into something with research
it's less guesswork the problem is that
research takes time
and we're so busy doing all these other
things usually what ends up happening is
we get down it's like okay
uh what are we looking at today and then
we kind of scramble around for the first
half hour hour just figuring out what
we're going to look at
and then we do it yeah i i the part that
i just really like about vfx rs react is
there's still the aspect of
i have a cool clip i saw this weekend
and i can't wait to see how
sam react to it that is true i mean we
do try to preserve some of the
the unknown so it's like i will research
something that nico doesn't and then
nikki will research something that
the other two won't and so then um we
still kind of have a little bit of that
guesswork going on which i really enjoy
yeah it was the natty reacts dude yeah
it was the
the ghost ghostbusters ghostbusters
investors there's that episode that was
the 100th that was
okay that one captain disillusion
episode was like look at them and their
entirely authentic reactions
it's like those are authentic and mr d
captain d maybe turn it up a little bit
but
so jake podcast 100 in three weeks
yeah so we need to come up with
something for it we can't just do i mean
we could just do a normal episode but
can we do a live we could do a live one
no okay
i feel like we should play some sort of
game that's sort of
different than we can cook a hot
breakfast right here
rooster teeth does that you know that's
why i said it
i didn't think he'd catch on i was gonna
it was gonna be my reveal
yeah raise your teeth if they have uh i
forget if it's like once a year i think
every year on a certain day
they have they basically just cook up
some pancakes and sausages and bacon
yeah maybe it's just pancakes actually i
don't know it's been a little while
since i've seen him
the last one i saw it was just pancakes
and bernie was adding all kinds of
whatever people wanted into the pancake
and so nice yeah and then he was serving
them out it was pretty funny
talk about old podcasts they've been in
three different decades
yeah wow yeah that's crazy not really
started in a dorm room
yeah awesome yeah ah
rooster teeth yeah and now i think
bernie lives in australia i think
really wait why are we or in texas i
think he
australia or texas what
he might be i think you mean austin
texas
australia and texas australia from
california
get all these damn people really stupid
right now
but i'm fairly certain because bernie
stepped away from the company last year
or maybe it was the year before that at
the end of the year
uh to basically raise his new son with
his
wife ashley okay um maybe maybe
girlfriend
i'm not exactly sure what their
relationship status is but he was
basically just stepping away from the
company and now i'm actually starting to
talk about things i don't exactly know
so
i don't like this but uh yeah i thought
there was something about him moving to
australia
because he actually used to live in
australia okay and
and i thought they had moved there he
now has a ranch they have like emus and
stuff
really uh or not emu's alpacas what are
you calling
there's a lot of information guys i
think he has llamas he's got like
pigs even those are this bird from
australia though oh yeah
they're birds yeah i don't think he has
emus well hopefully somebody can tell us
in the comments maybe we can hit them
oh they're gonna correct me i got this
all wrong i don't
know why do i even talk about
[Laughter]
does bernie ride kangaroos let us know
in the comments have you guys ever seen
a kangaroo in real life
yeah they're muscular they're cheery
looking
they are so muscular yeah do you see
that video the guy punching the kangaroo
yeah can't believe you did that they
kind of stared at each other for a
moment and then like
okay i guess i'll run away now those
things will mess you up i wouldn't want
to do that
i hear they can rip your guts open with
their feet yeah that's what they do
really yeah they grab their little tiny
t-rex arms yeah they take the giant
figure
and they like tear your stomach open
with their toes claws on their toes
yeah dude you know like a cat when you
play with his tummy and it takes his
time legs it goes like you know
scratch against your hands yeah it's
like that but with your guts yeah
and like bodybuilder muscles yeah like
they actually look
toned and ripped there's definition to
their muscles which is not something i
commonly see on
animals yeah they look like they look
like they hit the gym all the time
yeah yeah those kangaroos
yeah australia is such a weird place
he's got some really messed up wildlife
hey guys you're talking
about dragon texas
we just got an australian tangent now do
you guys realize that we're the last
generation to
see the world go from having corners of
it still be mysterious to be entirely
mapped
what yeah like when we were kids there's
still like parts of the world that were
kind of dark and mysterious like
satellites hadn't really taken pictures
of it yet oh okay like there's still
uncontacted tribes of people that have
literally never
oh that's true that's true i guess the
ocean is the equivalent of that now yeah
i guess there's
the ocean so but there's nobody living
under the ocean yeah who cares
supposedly
yeah and then with our time now it's
like the entire world there's literally
like
it's like you're playing an rpg it's
like you're playing civilization there's
fog on the map
there's zero fog on the map there was
some fog on the map when we were kids
there's no more fog
it's pretty wild yeah it's not like
you're in an episode of the truman show
now because i mean that was his calling
i mean there are three cameras pointed
at me four cameras
oh my god so our workplace is the truman
show
it's there right cool
everything's green screen around us
all right well let us know about episode
100 i don't know yet
we'll brainstorm yeah yeah please
comment down below that's what i should
do for
it it's got to be something special in
the meantime
i was thinking about episode 100.
[Music]
i like the guitar playing you know what
for those of you guys listening you said
i'm not a huge fan of musical intros
tough beans i like it every time
jake plays these guitar songs for me you
all get to just enjoy them also
all right that's it what come on jake oh
okay
all right i'll do a whole song for you
come on take us higher
all right yeah
yeah can you take me
higher
[Music]
there's gonna be birds just like ren
there's gonna be
comments just like then there's gonna be
a whole 100 show
can you take me higher
you went for 100 episode 100 we go
oh that was pretty good see that's what
i was looking for that's it yeah yeah in
three two one